I almost
said tut tu tu tu tu tu tu Oh kairi nasai masu I'm moving today I'm moving, I'm moving and I'm grooving and I'm smooving Hi Welcome in, welcome in but okay good my thing is working hello hello thank you guys so much you guys were we're we're doing it before stream i heard a new group called mvp is debuting soon well actually actually oh excuse me hold on um actually the group is called den sent you not of is the first letters of each member in the group um mint uh vicky and phoebe yeah mint vicky and phoebe so um actually the group is called densetsu.exe but i can't believe that i can i can do this i can't i can't believe i could just put up my glasses and and fix your and and and call out your mistakes Vicky's name?
No, I couldn't remember if it was Phoebe or Vicky first.
I was like, is it MPV or
MVP?
That's why.
For real though, congratulations.
Thank you!
Yes, our little group, Our little group will be debuting this route.
Oh, I forgot to put the video.
I was going to have it on the...
On the...
The starting...
Soon!
Starting...
Starting Scoon!
Yui, yui, yui, yui, yui, yui.
Yui, yui, yui, yui, yui.
The dot EXE is important.
Don't forget it.
Exactly.
It's there too.
Start.
I was gone for a couple days, but I did stream once.
Oh my gosh, I said I was going to stream more than once, and I was so optimistic.
I keep doing this.
I keep doing this where I'm like, oh, I could stream.
I could stream.
But honestly, it was such a crazy amount of time that I was so tired.
I'm glad I could at least stream once, though.
oh but it's all good it's all good we were so busy i was i was 110 stream no no no my my data plan caps it's all good ambition is cute i the thing is too is like i bring my whole travel setup which is very heavy and i want to i feel like if i i i bring it to use it,
obviously.
Like, I don't bring it just to... Just to carry it.
Like, I want to use it.
And so I become very ambitious.
And even if I can stream once, I feel like that's worth it more than...
If I can, you know, if I bring it and stream once, it's more worth it than... than not... than bringing it and not using it at all, obviously.
I missed you when you were gone.
Ah, I missed you guys, too!
It was my birthday a few days ago!
Ben!
As well as roughly a year since I started watching you.
I wanted to say thank you for being my comiosy.
That I look forward to the upcoming debut.
Thank you!
Happy birthday, Ben!
Ben Birdland.
Ben, what is it?
Ben Birdland?
Or Ben Birdland?
Ben-Beland.
Ben?
Blah, blah, blah.
Hold on, I'm kidding.
Happy birthday Oh geez Oh geez No thank you for serving me I got FNAF 2 Popeyes combo yesterday Give me food poisoning Wait J-R Wait my tummy also hurt today But I did not have Popeyes The cake was super mid and worst of all They didn't even give me any packaging related to the movie Wait that's the worst You need to go brrrrr.
Did you really spend $110 in data because you missed us?
I said so many times that my thing caps at like $80, okay?
It caps at 80.
So, no, I didn't spend $110.
This is false advertising.
12 months with Rita!
Yes!
Rita!
Thank you.
80 dollars a sub much better than 110 yeah it's okay it's all good it's all good and what's so silly too is the day after so basically what had happened is i tried to sign in so backing up i was at a hotel i was at a i was at a hotel and you'll have to sign in with your login to get free are we following I have an account at said hotel chain so I went to log in and when I went to log in so I could get my free Wi-Fi it said it said hey there's trouble logging in right now we can't log you in but now that I think about it I think the hotel had Wi-Fi that you could pay for was like ten dollars wait a second wait
a second but though but it probably would have been so bad it probably would have been unstreamable she bit on my rate to like up here's another gig question mark.
Oh, thank you.
Wait, oh gosh.
It probably would have been really bad.
It probably would have been so bad.
Like, the quality.
For the why, my God, sir, no!
I don't bring it up so that you guys will donate, though, please.
Thank you for that, Christopher.
Thank you.
Oh, thank you so much.
Hindsight is 2020, and at a significant discount.
It was...
Well, I wanted you guys to have the best quality of just my voice, no video.
Wait, there was kind of video.
I had the video playing in the background.
Do you guys hear that popping?
Or is it my headphones?
I mean, that was my birthday last weekend, get a happy birthday from my Kamiyoshi.
That's good!
Wait, you do hear it?
What is that?
Weird.
Haunted.
It was like It was ASMR.
You don't hear it anymore though, right?
I don't either.
Is it...
It's .exe because you guys are evil!
Like Sonic...
Every .exe is evil.
So true.
Me, brain smooth and tired today.
Make you make brain good and full of energy.
Brain go, yippee!
Also, milk.
Thank you for the...
Super chat.
07, 07.
Yeah, don't hear it anymore.
Strange.
I think it's because maybe I was clicked out of the game.
MVP drowned.
Haunted is on brand.
True.
Now, Miasa would like to buy one megabyte per...
hour wi-fi access please did the gummy bear charger come on the rich you guys you guys might they
said it would explode they said it would stay tuned
i'm so sad i'm actually so i wouldn't i don't care if it'll explode i had a little gummy bear on it i don't care
too much power
Charger exploding is on bread.
I know.
So I think I'll give up.
How sad.
I'm so sad.
I mean...
Where else?
Now, I hope they realize that there's a market for very cute chargers.
All right, Anchor.
Get on it, please.
Put gummy bears on your...
chargers.
I need it right now.
I'll buy five.
I'll do it.
Thank you guys for all the super chats.
Thank you so much.
How... Minky now has pay per stream?
No!
Oh no, all dot EXEs are evil.
Better delete them from the computer right now!
No, do not do this.
Yeah, do not do that.
Looking forward to MVP debuts?
Thank you!
Can't wait to see you all shining bright.
making your dreams of reality.
Also, I miss you, Vito.
Thank you, Phil!
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
I tried Albany's gummies before.
Not Albany.
Is this a D's joke?
I hope you're having a great day, Vito.
You too!
Almost got the one-year badge.
Got a new job today, Paul!
Thank you!
Oh, congratulations.
Pretty good day so far.
Have a good stream.
Have a good day.
Have a better day.
Have the bestest day.
Keep having a good day.
Keep going.
Wait, oh my gosh.
I'm trying to read the super chats that I missed earlier.
But the YouTube sucks!
Sorry.
Okay, I think I got it.
We just turned the game music all the way up.
It's like pretty high right now.
I think it'll, uh, I think right now it's just the ambience, but it should, it should be up.
How was they cancel my gummy bear charger?
They said it would explode the most mint-fantile thing ever.
Can you ever, wait, have you ever seen the U-green?
Uno.
It's kind of cute.
I haven't.
Is that a charger?
Is it okay if I name my new kitty after you?
Of course!
But is it going to be me kitty?
Hmm.
Yul Green approve.
I usually get Anchor stuff.
Not the card game.
Hold on.
I'm going to look it up like right now.
Yul.
Yul Green Uno.
I've never heard of this brand before.
Wait, that's kind of cute.
That is cute.
It's like a little robot guy.
He's smiling even.
Wait, this is so cute.
He's kind of like...
That's what he's like.
Anchor is pretty solid for all cords and power banks.
I, yeah, I feel like they've got a good thing going.
But I'll look into this U-Green.
Thank you for the suggestion.
That's cute.
They're so fast.
Wow!
Ghost cutie.
Wait, that's 15 months is more than a year.
Thank you though.
Yesterday was my birthday.
Gonna get a super minky birthday song even though it was a day late.
Goopy!
Happy birthday!
Happy birthday.
So many birthdays I missed.
I'm sorry, I'm sorry, I'm sorry.
I'm sorry, I'm sorry.
I feel this next...
So I know I was gone for a couple days.
And then Sunday, I'm also starting gone.
So I'm for until December.
I feel like I'm missing so much for like two weeks even.
I feel though this trip, my upcoming trip is pretty busy.
It was a vacation, a short vacation.
And then it suddenly was just like, oh, you're in Japan.
Do you want to do this work?
And I'm like, I can't say no.
And then they're like, do you want to do this work?
So I apologize in advance.
I got extended because I can't say no.
But it's other things that I want to do.
One of them's really cool.
I hope it works out.
But I feel that with this upcoming trip, because it's so busy for me, I probably will be streaming like night, Japan time, which is gonna be early morning for you guys.
I don't know.
I'm gonna try and do some streams.
I'm gonna try and wake up early because a lot of my plans are involving me waking up early and going to do something.
And so I'm like, well, I even have time to stream in the morning in Japan so that I can then stream at my normal time.
Some of us are on JST.
Then it'll be perfect for you.
Maybe.
Night Japan is perfect EU.
Sounds great.
Yeah, there you go.
So, hmm.
So, the timing might be a little varied.
But I'll do my best to stream.
Even if it's morning of EST.
Yes, yes.
Just giving you guys a heads up since my morning so far.
So busy, it seems.
right now.
Can't wait for Friday.
Me too.
Actually, I can't wait for Friday.
I still have so much to do.
Isn't it a nice surprise this game in Okami where peak video games are art games for my teenage years?
I played Okami, but I'm surprised and I always saw this game.
I don't know why I never played it.
I think maybe I did not have the console.
What was it?
Like PS3?
But I did play Olkami.
Yeah, I didn't have PS3.
I didn't get one until I was like, okay.
Time to stream.
And play Metal Gear Solid 4.
So, yeah, this game kind of fell off my radar.
And now I get to play it now.
And so I'm very, very excited.
I'm very excited.
Hi Mito, can you guesstimate with your XOL powers when a boat sailing from Japan?
47 degrees, 9.
Oh, what's that mean?
Oh, shoot, what's, uh, hope you enjoy journey.
Thanks!
I saw some funny comments kind of discussing my job that I described in my last, in my previous stream, the work stream, which is funny because I did no work, but all I did was talk about my old work.
How funny.
I'll be doing so well.
It was my birthday this past weekend.
May I request the Metal Gear birthday song?
Ah!
So bad!
Happy birthday!
We'll sing this song for all the birthdays that I missed over the past couple of days.
Happy birthday.
Congratulations.
Happy birthday with salutations.
Happy birthday.
May your sky stay blue happy birthday to you happy birthday but yeah seeing people's people's reactions to that were very funny honestly I guess it yeah like there was you know I talked about it and I described it quite in a funny way.
It was also so long ago that I don't remember every little tiny aspect of it.
But then people were like commenting saying like, oh, she probably did something like this.
And I was like, oh yeah, I do remember doing that.
So it was, it was, yeah, it was a job.
And the thing too is like, we worked with some major like Japanese manufacturing companies, like the places that like build the big, the big like um hold on, uh, like construction um uh, construction like machinery so yeah,
I had to be, I had to be very accurate um Thank you, Vinto, smiling so much.
I hurt right now.
Vinto used to bint the boats.
I was interested to hear that in your last stream.
It was, I've, I've, as a, as someone who is dead, I have, uh, the phrase lived many lives.
It's quite accurate for me, maybe.
Do you know the other game?
What?
If you want to hear more about that, you can go to my previous stream.
We're going to play Journey!
Journey, journey, journey.
I'm very excited.
I saw that this one was pretty short, and I, unfortunately, I have meetings with the other Densitu Gurleys.
Well, not meetings, but we're meeting up basically every night this week.
So many, many things that we have to finalize and stuff.
Don't stop believing me, Tao!
Thank you!
So, yeah, busy, busy, busy, for sure.
So let's get started then.
Let's start.
Let's go on our journey!
Well, you end up playing with a wisp.
I don't know!
Isn't it like...
I don't know really anything about this game, but I think you get paired up with someone and it's random or something.
So excited for your idol debut.
Thank you!
Wow.
I'm playing PC on Steam, so.
Whoa.
Wow.
Was that me?
Yes.
I'm on controller.
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa, it's telling me to look around.
That's me.
That's telling me to move.
Look at the sand!
Oh, it looks so edible.
Oh, wow.
Wow!
Oh!
What did I do?
What is that?
Look at me, go!
Go, go, go, go.
You are good.
What?
Oh, whoa.
Heavy.
Look at that.
So cool.
Everyone has always been saying how beautiful and beautiful this game looks and sounds.
And I can see things right now.
Oh yeah he is.
Whoa!
Journey!
Just a small town girl.
Oh, we're still going.
What are these in the sand though?
They're not gravestones are they?
Is that gonna be me?
Hello?
You are called.
Scan my...
Scan for my mixtape.
Keyblade graveyard.
Oh my gosh.
These definitely...
They have like little symbols on them.
Are they different?
If they're different than their gravestones.
Hmm.
There's some boys up there.
Get those guys.
Wait.
Can I hop?
Okay, he hops all on his own.
Wait, is that my symbol?
No.
Who is it?
I'm calling somebody.
Pick up the phone.
What?
Whoa!
Oh, okay.
I can only do that when these guys replenish my thing.
Well, luckily there's many of them!
Oh, nice.
Nice roll.
Are they...
the spirits of my ancestors?
Well, I want to go in there, but I feel like I should be following.
Because...
Thank you.
Because there's this.
I feel like I should be following the path a little bit.
Good night means out.
Good night!
This is Anakin Skywalker's least favorite game.
Truly.
Scan it to use code boomerang ever.
We'll try going here first.
How do I meet somebody?
Who's gonna play with me?
One lucky person who's been waiting for someone else to join.
Playing journey for so many years.
What is this?
Oh!
Did I do
it?
Does anything in here match my thing?
My symbol, my QR code?
I don't think so.
See the graves?
It was this one that I think looked like it.
Ooh, the sound of the rocks is nice.
Okay, now they tell me to go this way.
Is this game pretty linear?
Please, magic cloth.
I want to fly in.
I wish to fly.
Yeah?
Okay.
More magic cloth!
Woohoo!
Um...
Thank you.
It looks so cute.
It does look pretty cute, though.
Oh.
I did not jump high enough.
Oh geez, okay.
That's fine.
What is this?
Somebody listen to my song!
Why is it glowing?
It's the only one, too.
Mysterious.
There's a glowing over there, too.
Whoa, whoa!
I need to get in there.
You can hold it for a bigger area?
Oh, thank you!
Open up!
Can you get me?
No.
They're trapped.
Oh, there's some trapped in here too!
Oh my gosh!
Give me more?
Please?
I'm hungry.
Thank you!
Oh, they're all trapped!
Interesting.
Happy day Saturday.
Happy birthday, other wasp too!
Hatata!
Happy birthday!
There's...
Come on up.
Wait.
Oh, shoot.
Oh, I'm bad at it.
These guys are skipped.
When do I meet somebody else?
Hello.
Please?
Please.
Oh.
Thank you.
Oh, up here, up here.
Hop, hop, hop, hop.
Hop, hop.
Did we learn a new one?
Whoa!
Okay?
Interesting.
Oh, whoa, whoa.
I ran out.
My scarf got longer.
That's what happened.
What's going on up here?
Ah!
Whoa!
Need!
Free!
Be free!
Yeah, give me more.
Whoa!
Nice.
But there was one.
That one.
I want that one as well.
Before we do that, we can always, we can always.
Stick the landing.
Yes, longer.
Longer, longer.
Okay.
It still dies so fast though.
You're a landing.
Yes, they all want to touch my scarf.
So if I do this...
So awesome.
So what's this going on up here?
Oh, oh wait, uh, one more?
One more?
It's so satisfying.
Oh, did we just sit down?
Like a little cat.
Our character does kind of look like a cat, no?
Hello?
It's a light volcano.
Oh.
character is so cute
the birds make the crops grow it's their poop and that makes the people grow and then the people get cats they build bigger trees so
we must restore the birds so that we can bring back the plants and the people.
That's what we must do.
So smart.
I know.
Do you guys see that?
There's my partner.
Who are you?
They're running away.
She is an archaeologist.
I'm a geologist.
Player two?
I'm guessing I couldn't open the other stuff in there because I just left.
Hopefully.
Can you make a funny face?
Like the hat or like really funny?
Like this.
Player two.
Where are you?
The sounds in this game are just so long.
nice okay I see that down there let's go get it
someone must be playing it too right right now you can have your chance to there
they are
what's what's happening to me Wow oh Wow yes extend your your scarf hi player two i've never played this game before have you
they said yes and how about you how are you today i'm good thank you whoa are you glowing
are you a wisp chirp it oh chirp if you're a wisp I can't tell.
What is this?
Oh, oh, cool.
What's happening?
Release them!
Release the birds!
Chirp, three chirps if you're a wisp.
One, two, three, four.
That was four.
Three, if you're a whisperer.
That's three?
Can't tell.
One, two, three.
That was three!
Nice!
Come on up!
There's also one over there.
What?
we gotta keep uh making them wait oh oh oh oh this is me laughing at you ha ha ha ha oh oh
oh oh oh oh wait do I need there we go more birds
there's this one too this one looks like it'll connect yeah you need help whoa what's happening I'm releasing birds I
can't count the three is definitely one of us don't be mean what's up yeah what's wrong this guy oh you released it there was a big one.
There's actually so many here.
There's that big guy.
But I also want to extend my I want to extend my thing.
My scarf.
Am I going to be going crazy with exploring?
This is part of the journey, no?
You can extend Send those with the beeps too.
Oh, you can!
This way over here, yeah, yeah!
Let me know also if the music gets a little too loud.
I know you guys say loud, we'll say louder or something, but...
Good morning!
Me too, me too!
Nice.
Wait, there's still sparkle.
What's the sparkle for?
Hmm.
Mysterious.
Wait, so if I...
Whoa!
Cool!
Maybe just to let you know it was there.
Ayya!
Whoa,
whoa, whoa!
Nice!
Yeah, I was gonna say this will make a big guy.
Supposed to get the little pieces, too.
Little pieces?
The thing, the glowy bits?
I feel like you have to, so you can extend your...
Oh!
So you can extend your scarf.
Oh, I think that...
Did it, no?
But there's still more to see.
We're not leaving yet.
I'm the leader of this coup.
Not yet.
We must get more birds.
Pronto.
Eyeball.
The journey for the longer scarf.
The longest scarf.
The top chicken.
Yeah, we're birds and we're birding it up.
Oh.
Get up there.
Wait, there we go.
Wait, there's something behind there.
Aibo!
Aibo, look!
Oh!
Aibo, Aibo!
It's lore!
It's lore, look!
What is that?
Cities, they had cities.
cities even.
They were an advanced society.
Can you fill me up?
Thank you.
There's... Oh, that one didn't open anything.
That, I can see it's open.
We have to get up there.
I think the best way to get that maybe from here we'll make it.
Or if we go from the top.
I think from we can make it, though.
Oh, my God.
Ah, nice.
She's too good.
Use the boards.
Oh, I forgot.
It's fine.
We didn't need them.
Settling in with some homemade curry.
Ah, Chucky!
Miss Consanity.
Thank you.
If I died and came back as a flying dish towel in the desert, I'd be pretty mad.
Why?
I think it'd be quite relaxing.
No?
Just me?
Listen to the song of my people!
Hey!
Top me off!
Thank you.
Wait, they did not top me off!
Chatty over here.
Here we go!
Do we get everything in here, you think?
I don't think I see anything else.
Yeah, I did?
Okay, glue.
Should be.
Cool.
Okay, I get this side.
Eyeball.
Good job!
Um...
Oh.
We have to sit.
Oh my gosh, they really look like cats.
Yes?
The great cat.
Oh my god.
Wait, it's kind of freaky.
That looks like a bird.
That's a bird.
War.
Then they got cats.
They built big towns.
Wait, that looks like the thing we just kind of made, right?
And trains!
They were so advanced!
It's a big bird!
And electricity!
Is it because of the scarves?
The little birds?
The fabric birds?
They use the cloth for power!
Glad you're home and happy exploring, Possum!
Thank you!
Hope to be back for the end.
It's my birthday today!
Oh my gosh, King of Tendies!
Happy birthday!
It's round of love for Mickey and Whisper that I've been here.
While I've been here.
Happy birthday!
Wow.
There's something...
There's like a shooting star above the...
Above the...
The volcano.
It's pink!
I'll release you.
What's that sound, though?
Whoa!
Different type of bird!
Oh my gosh!
No item name, thank you so much!
That's why I got to thank you!
I was like looking at your name like How do I say this?
How do I say this?
What's over here?
He's calling too.
He wants us to follow.
Oh.
Thank you!
They're so nice!
Oh, goodbye.
Where are
we going?
We're just following him.
Am I playing with a viewer or Rando?
We think it's a viewer, no?
Do a little chirp if you're a viewer.
I feel like that was too early.
See?
Oh, he wants his friend!
Release the friend.
I don't think randomly people are playing this game in 2025.
I think that's the same.
Wow!
I have my own magic card.
Oh, oops, sorry.
Wait, can I get back on?
Wait, oh, don't move.
Don't move.
Wait, don't move.
Wait, oh shoot.
Can somebody grab me?
Wait.
Can somebody pick me up?
Please.
Can you pick me up?
No?
No!
I thought I could move!
My magic carpet.
What's in here?
Cats.
Meow, meow, meow, meow, meow, meow, meow, meow, meow, meow, meow, meow, meow, meow, meow, meow, meow, meow.
The cats and the birds.
Will you pick me up?
Pick me up?
Pick me up.
No, I know you wanted to.
I know.
I know you wanted to.
You were so close.
You were glowing!
I heard you needed to be lit.
Ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha!
Yeah, oh, we're going this way?
Okay, no biggie.
Pick me up!
Pick me up, please!
Come on, come on!
We're both struggling, me and my partner.
It's a sound, it's so loud.
Come on!
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Come here, hold on, birds.
Hold on.
Yes.
Oh, I think I got it.
What do you do when Minto leaves?
Wait for her to get back.
I'm back!
I'm back for a few days.
Minto flying around.
like a grain of sand.
Please pick- please upies!
Please upies, please!
I guess we can constantly be jumping though because they'll give us constant like...
They'll constantly be refreshing our...
Where are they going?
Our scarf.
Oh, this way.
No, no ABJ.
Unless it's A, B, J.
No, sorry, wait.
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
We're lagging.
Whoa, we're lagging.
A.
A, B.
Dot, dot, dot, dot, dot, dot, dot, dot.
J.
You get it?
What are we talking about?
Always.
Always be jumping.
It can be abbreviated.
You just have to be careful about it, you know?
What are you doing?
I hear noise, but I don't know where it's from.
Where's my partner?
Friend?
Oh, oh, they want this guy out.
I see.
I see, I see.
Don't worry, I got him.
Oh, you got him.
You got him.
Good job.
What do they want now?
Oh, wait.
Can we go inside?
No.
Where do they go?
What do they want now?
This away.
Time to leave.
Always be journeying.
Yeah.
Oh, my gosh.
I'm flying so much.
Give me!
Or don't.
Okay, thank you.
I wish you could jump, jump though.
You can't jump if you have no...
You know?
We'll let them free!
Oh, there's a thing, I see it!
I see it, I see it, thank you.
Good job.
They build mechs!
Wow.
They build mechs too.
Metal gear?
Where are we going?
Gosh, this game is so pretty.
This is where we came from, no?
Cloth gear.
Look how shiny the sand is.
and everything is
there an achievement for singing so many times I'm gonna journey after week oh after after work after work for one dollar tacos yeah I might am I going the right way scarves yeah okay my partner just said that's right wish Metal Gear get nominated at TGA I did it not I actually I have I never I never know when these things are happening this looks kind of spooky wait where are they taking us um scarves are we going the right way wait why am I lagging so bad I changed I thought this game wouldn't be very heavy so I changed the graphics to high.
They were like automatically put at medium.
But now I'm nervous.
Could be the network.
That's what I'm thinking.
It's like that kind of lag, you know.
Did they go up?
Where are they going?
Seems to be the case.
Around here?
Or something?
Can I...
Oh gosh.
I'm stuck.
Um, thank you.
Thank you.
Oh, something's...
Oh, he's got me.
Thank you!
Oh, wait, is that a bad guy or...
Oh, it's like a machine.
Whoa!
A little bit spoopy now.
You okay?
Don't fall!
Whoa, it's making me.
Oh, it's freaky.
Whoa.
There's so many trapped in there.
We'll set you free.
Right over here.
Are you going to help us up?
Help me up.
Thank you.
Let's go, Aibo.
Did
that do it?
Did we get it?
Yeah.
My wife missed you.
We're both very excited about density.exe.
Also, the Minto Pansu didn't fit one of...
I say yeah.
Scarfens.
They're scarfing it down.
Yeah,
we want to do lots of covers together.
Oh, more.
Bigger cities.
More, taller.
Wait, are these all like power?
Basically, they're not houses.
They're like energy.
They're energy centers, kind of.
Wow.
Or maybe?
Be free!
They do kind of remind me of like, yeah, like dolphins or whales or something.
Power plants!
Yeah, that's the word that I was thinking of.
They're waiting for us, eyeball.
There's two that are waiting for us.
Whoa.
Wow!
Pink.
I'm I'm zooming watch this sick flip
Wow, oh dang it I dropped to Wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait yes
Weeeee She's game and
Wow!
I'll land right!
Did something.
Oh, released more.
Good job!
What else we got going on?
Is this a thing?
This looks like a thing.
A little...
...
Good job!
Good job, Aibo!
Wait, there's like some guys over here.
You could see me in the corner leaving this cousin?
Yay!
Okay, hold on.
There were guys over here.
Now that I know that there's sometimes like secrets, it makes me wonder, you know?
What could be up here?
Aha!
And the search.
More lore!
Hey, Eyeball.
They're just more cats in cities.
Cats in boxes.
So now we got...
Do you see that up there, Eyeball?
Eyeball, there's another thing.
You said, yes, I do.
I do see it.
Great dominto, sama.
I'm having cheesecake for Thanksgiving.
Can't decide what flavor.
Oreo?
Oreo.
Wait, how do we get up there?
Here?
Right here.
Okay.
I'm watching you.
Ah, go get it!
Go get your dreams!
up!
Wait, am I gonna make it?
Wait, eyeball.
Eye boy, I don't know if I'm gonna make it.
Eye boy!
I made it.
Just kidding.
I made it!
I'm guessing that probably was...
Oh my gosh, it's so smoky.
That probably was like the only secret in this area.
We got everything else, I think.
So we can continue onwards.
You ready?
Oh, I flew hard.
I flew like, eyeball, eyeball, I kept, I couldn't stop.
Oh my gosh, we're still going.
Let's go.
You think you'd want an actual churro?
If I, actually, like, cinnamon cheesecake sounds pretty good.
I'm not gonna lie.
I don't know, but I'm such an Oreo fan of anything.
Oreo drink.
Yeah.
I don't want to miss the secrets.
Whoa, whoa.
Oh, okay.
Down here?
Oh, shoot.
Wee!
I already missed a secret.
Oh, well.
It's my first time playing.
I'm gonna miss secrets.
You missed it, but it's okay.
My bad.
I tried.
I tried looking.
Oh, my God.
It's so orange.
reminds me of a tangerine drink.
Wow!
Oh my gosh, cinema.
Whoa!
Oh, I almost ran into the wall.
Oh!
It's so pretty.
I'm going.
We're still going?
I can't see anything.
It's so orange.
Oops, I'm orange.
Up there maybe is something if I can even I don't even know if I could reach that maybe from like over here.
I don't think so.
They forced me back.
Who's calling?
Whoa.
We have Breaking Bad up in here.
Okay I know the sand looks so soft but I'm sure this is hard.
Are you okay?
Okay, good.
Before we do that, there's some stuff I want to explore.
Like, what's this over here?
Anything?
It might be nothing.
It could be something.
It is something!
Good job, team.
I got a spam call when you said that.
What is going on there?
Do you get it, I boy?
Whoa, mouth!
I'll follow you.
Is there anything over there?
I don't know if there is anything here.
No.
The people divided the cities, maybe.
To imagine all of this was such lush green, you know?
Alright, ready, eyeball!
Good job.
Yeah, good job, good job.
It was basically timed perfectly.
What happened to them?
I don't know.
It's part of the journey to find out.
Look how long my scarf is now.
Basically a cape.
Oh no!
The power, the electricity!
Severe.
The machinery!
What happened to it?
Uh-oh.
Wait, that doesn't...
Wait, this seems really bad.
Wait.
This does not seem good.
War.
They fought over it.
No!
Let's go, Aibo.
Into the abyss.
I want to hear Mint say the phrase.
War.
War has changed.
That?
Wow.
The sand is so shiny.
Look at the kick up more sand.
New day.
Kick it up.
Kick up...
Kick up the sand.
Yeah!
Kick up that sand.
Porker is cooking now to watch OSI.
Yummy!
What are these?
These look special.
Just a rack.
Oh, okay.
Oh, there are some dolphins down here.
Oh!
It looks like we're at the bottom of the ocean, no?
Whoa!
Are these the trains?
They look like it now, right?
Is there anything in here?
You check out that one, I boy.
Check out this one.
Call if you need help.
Oh!
In here!
Get your thing.
You're welcome.
I don't know what they were saying.
I don't really understand their accent.
Thank you.
Mint.
That's what they said.
Whoa.
Wow.
Okay, so it's meant to look like the bottom of the ocean.
Because look at that.
Wow.
Whoa.
Whoa!
Wait.
There's one in here.
Now you are Kelp.
Jeffrey, hi!
Yep.
I got it too.
Wait, is there one down here?
Is that one?
No.
My eyes do deceive me.
Kelp.
is cute i want to know who's playing with me i want to see them in chat is it are you where are you wait oh i don't think i'll make it oh oh
oh wait it did help actually oh Oh.
We?
Oh, oh, oh, yeah.
Is this the way?
Oh, there's my abbo.
You were in the kelp.
What are you doing in there?
They will show their name after the credits?
Really?
Wait, are you still in here?
Oh, you're gone.
Hello.
Unless you were talking in chat.
Hold on, I'm making sure there's nothing in there.
Oh, jellies!
Jellies!
Jelly, jelly, jelly.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa!
There's one up here!
Nice.
Good job, team.
Wow.
It's so beautiful.
It's so pretty, it makes me mad.
Oh, there's nothing up here, I think.
On this?
No, it doesn't seem like it.
We're going down!
Oh!
Ouch.
You see anything over here?
No, it doesn't look like it.
Sorry, Eye Boy, I love exploring too much.
It's okay, Minto!
That's what they said.
Nothing here.
This is spooky.
This is quite spooky.
Are there bosses in this game?
How do you even fight?
Yeah?
Oh my gosh.
Um, okay, I spoke.
Did I die?
Get up?
It was so loud.
That spooked a heckie out of me.
Okay, did we keep going?
It was so loud.
Watch out for those.
I think
you lost Scarf.
Did I?
No.
They damage your scarf permanently.
Uh-oh.
Wait, is this a stealth mission?
Oh my gosh.
Eyebo, I'm scared.
Eyebo, eyebo, I'm scared.
Hey, we weren't going after that.
Is this now a sneaking mission?
Oh my gosh.
Oh my god, the music is all scary all of a sudden.
Daibo!
Daibo, I'm scared!
We should get higher up ground?
So that if we need to slide, we can slide.
You see my vision?
Wait, did we get up here?
Or anything?
Now my scarf looks so short now.
So sad.
Oh my god.
He's scanning.
Ah!
Sorry.
Oh my god, this is...
That's an alive one!
Okay.
Good to know.
Oh my gosh.
Eyeball, I'm scared.
Eyeball, I didn't know this was going to be a horror game.
Eyeball.
Eyeball, I'm scared.
What if we die?
Okay, that's one, but now there's two of them.
And there's the second one above us?
Oh my god, get under here!
Don't, don't, don't.
How do we get out of this mess?
All big Metal Gear reference.
I got scared while riding the Supa.
He's circling, yeah!
He's spawn camping.
How do we get out of here?
You take the lead, I bold.
Oh!
Don't take the lead, Aibo.
Aibo, take the wheel!
I'll follow you.
I think this one's also gonna come alive though, no?
So yeah, I'll run up here.
It's gonna be loud!
Aibo!
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I am going to turn it down just a tad more for me.
Okay.
All right, we're good.
There's one over there, isn't there?
I see it, I see it.
Nice.
Such a good eyeball, yeah.
I saw him with his eye, but I don't...
Oh, I see orange over there.
Okay.
Like, I saw...
I had seen a blue light, you know.
Oh, my gosh.
Wait.
This one's gonna come alive, isn't it?
No?
It's not?
Okay.
Now I don't know who to trust.
Oh, here we go.
I guess if you move in front of them more of them More of them wake up or something Oh my gosh oh my gosh oh my gosh There we go You can trust me me though Yeah I can Oh my gosh oh my gosh Will he come up here?
No Yes No
I see something down there do they say follow my lead wait i think i've messed up oh my gosh eyeball
what the heck just happened where am i
okay i think they just said see i told you okay we were
that was scary
Bird person.
Oh my gosh, is that why the mountain is split?
They're all dead!
Oh, my...
Or asleep.
One or the other.
Mountains and mountains of graves.
It looks nighttime.
It could be...
They're not...
They're...
You know, they sleep at night.
Oh, they're...
They become stars in the sky!
Oh!
Me!
Sleeping under the sand.
They're hibernating.
Let's go, Aibo.
Good job, by the way.
So are we, like, protected in here?
Can we leave?
Whoa.
The gravestones.
So these were gravestones.
Full of sand and whimsy.
Sneak through the underground passage without tearing your scarf.
Wait, I got an achievement!
So wait, maybe I didn't lose any of my scarf.
Yippee!
So I did it.
Okay.
No hit run.
If you heard that, that was my phone.
I kicked off my chair.
Oopsie.
What's this?
It's my stage.
Clumsy Ghost Breaks mode.
No, I have a screen protector on, but it's gotten a little bumpy.
It's gotten a little...
It's...
Yeah.
Um, it has, it doesn't have cracks in it, but it has indents in there for sure.
Wow!
What is it?
What happened?
Me!
And the graves!
Whoa!
And me!
Now we can just jump as...
Whoa!
Interesting.
What do you see?
I see it!
Oh, oops.
I fell in the water.
Thank you!
Is there anything...
Let's go to this one.
In here, maybe?
If I...
If I yell really loud...
Okay, nothing happens.
Oh, over there.
Maybe.
Okay.
Hold on, I'm going to replenish here.
Thank you.
Good job, Aibu.
There's eyes!
That's eyes!
The water.
The jellyfish!
Oh, oh, the critters.
I kept saying birds, but they're fish.
I called them birds.
But they're fish.
They're all little fish.
Look at these, even these guys, they're not tiny cloth birds.
They're fish.
Wait, was anything in here?
Oh, it's so beautiful.
They evolved or devolved.
Depending.
We're going high.
We're going up.
Oh, no, no, no.
Where are you?
Where are you, I bull?
Over there.
Oh gosh.
Oh, oh, I see you.
Thank you.
I'm blind.
Good eyeball.
Thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you.
Okay.
Where are you going?
I'm going up.
We're going up.
Oh, help me.
Yeah, thank you.
I made it, somehow.
Oh, good job.
Hello.
Where do we go from here?
I'm trying to find...
Oh, up there, up there.
Yuppup.
Nice.
Follow the scarf animal.
That's us.
Oh, that's me.
I'm blocking the cutscene.
Whoa, whoa, big animal!
Good thing they're friends.
Oh my god.
Whoa.
Wait, what's down there?
Did we already...
Oh, these are the things that we already did.
I'm coming.
I'll get in there.
Oh gosh.
We're good.
Oh, I'm good.
I'm fine.
So cool!
Gosh, our scarves are gonna be so long.
Where'd that guy go?
Yeah, those are the things that we already unlocked.
Okay.
Come on, buddy.
Did you make it?
Yeah?
Okay.
We made some stairs!
There it is!
Our stairs!
What do you see?
Over here?
What?
Oh, there's another one!
No, we already did this one, though.
Yeah, how are they able to know that we're doing this stuff?
Did they see the future?
I'm not sure.
I like how we float every time we get on these, it's cool.
Yes, more, more, mine and craft.
The prophecy.
Yeah, that would make sense, huh?
Oh.
Meow.
Wow.
I love the fish.
I want scarfish.
Okay.
Do it.
And then we go downstairs and there's fireworks!
It's gonna keep rising?
I love energy water.
This is how you feel drinking five...
Wait, that's the gum.
Did we see all the... Did we see the...
Oh, they're...
They're all like lighting up here.
Oh, see?
See?
Like that?
Cool!
Me when I drink five gum.
I don't know how many pieces of gum are in my tummy.
Hopefully not so many.
Apparently swallowing gum isn't bad.
Mama!
Yes, I did this.
I did this.
This is my journey.
I crossed the deserts and I made the bridges and I hopped.
And I saw the buildings and I ran down the stairs.
I went underground.
And I, that was scary.
I don't want to go back there.
Oh, now we're going to crawl.
We're going to crawl through the wind.
Up to the top, top, tippy top mountain.
You and Ible.
Yeah.
There was at least one roll of bubble tape in my belly.
We gotta crawl!
We can reach the lips of the mountain!
And give it a big ol' smooch.
Crawling in my crawl!
Celeste time?
Oh geez.
Suddenly it turns into a seven hour stream.
Let's go eyeball.
We're gonna... Are you ready to crawl?
Are you ready to crawl?
Yes or no?
They said, yes, I'm ready to crawl, Minto.
That's what they said.
Is there anything up here?
Am I being two?
The snow!
I thought I had a dirty mind and then he said the same thing.
Dirty?
Our song has changed once again.
Oh, thank you!
Oh, wow, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
Do these activate?
Well, they do!
Cute!
It's so snowy here.
Oh, there's there's red guys too.
Wait, is that a bad guy?
He's nice now, right?
Yes.
Why does this game feel almost like playing Peek?
You go through all the different areas.
Ah!
Nope.
Oh, we're crawling!
Oh, we're crawling.
Oh, yeah.
Okay, nice.
Successfully crawled.
Okay, alright.
Oh no!
Ah!
Don't fly, Aibo!
Don't fly!
Ah!
Aibo, don't fly.
I think you have to wait behind a rock when it comes, right?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I was just thinking the same thing.
Oh, don't kick me out, though.
Gosh.
Why is the sand or the snow rumbling like that?
Let's get over to the next one.
The sky right here.
I think it can take cover behind the pillars.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's not like Titanic where only one person can can get under there, you know?
Or on top of there, I guess.
Run, run, run!
I will be careful.
Don't be Rose, I will.
I'll never let go!
Can we just go through?
Is it cool?
Yeah.
Oh no, now they're tinier.
Unless?
You are so chatty.
What's going on?
I'll never let go of Jack.
Let's go.
Wait.
Oh, that's a plant.
Are you okay?
Are you cold?
Yeah, it's so cold up here.
Don't worry.
My...
My controller is like...
buzzing like crazy if you like journey you might oh what was that you might like the game juicy sound is it it seems like you're like journey but journey into buzz buzz 18 but thank you oh no bad guy
why doesn't he like us why doesn't he like us oh you have to like keep doing this or else your scarf will freeze over okay whoa I think we're having some connection issues once again oh my gosh really struggling here okay it's journey but Celeste oh I see I see yeah come on come on keep going come on we're gonna make it we're gonna make it eyeball we can what's in here real quick maybe we could warm this place up a little bit place Celeste honestly I want to but I know it's so difficult
yeah the birds are back the Sun is shining oh wait what is there anything up here?
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, aha!
If there are birds, there is a secret.
Look at them staring at each other.
Wow.
Romeo and Juliet.
Celeste is not really that hard.
I've heard it's pretty difficult.
But I guess if you're good at platformers, then you know what would be.
It would be a breeze.
I'm not super used to platformers personally but you ready wait there's more didn't
look like it no okay
okay all right onwards nice and refreshed nice and warm my toes are toasty requires fast reaction celestos I see, I see.
Defrost!
I'm gonna go on it?
Okay.
Huddle for warmth.
Should we take our clothes off so it's skin-to-skin contact?
That'll probably be the most effective way, no?
I learned that and love Hina.
Um...
Are we in trouble?
Aibo!
No fly!
Aibo, are we in trouble?
Why is your scarf?
My scarf doesn't...
It doesn't freeze up so quickly like yours does.
Maybe it does.
Oh my gosh.
Oh.
How did I get on top?
I did not mean to do that.
Do you even have a skin under the cloth at this game?
Oh, in this game, I thought you meant like...
I was going to be like, well, you know, I'm all ectoplasm, but...
feel like skin a little.
Oh, my gosh.
Is that me?
Oh, my head's poking out.
I think we can make it.
I can't make it!
I made it.
I'm not gonna make it.
Scarf and Mito slippers stays on.
Look at back, Mito.
Thank you.
Where'd he go?
Where is he?
To the next thing.
What's that over there?
This guy's a pain in my butt.
Do do
do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do.
It didn't open anything.
Wait, I'm scared.
Okay, there he is.
Okay.
I think we just got to go for it, eyeball.
Do we go over there?
Ah!
My scarf is running so low!
Ah, warmth.
Are we, uh, I think we're okay, maybe?
He's not actively searching, I think we're okay.
What is that over there though?
Aybo, I want to go!
Oh my gosh, oh my gosh, wait, uh, oh shoot.
Aibo.
Aibo, did we go the other way?
Aibo, Aibo, Aibo, Aibo!
Secret is that way.
Oh, I see.
Should we try?
Are we gonna get caught?
Secrets are worth it?
Aibo!
Aibo, let's go to the secret!
I want to see it!
What is this?
Keep going.
Aibo!
We're both Screaming together.
Push, push, push, push, push, push, push.
Yes, nice.
Wait, it even has a second exit, so that's good.
Oh, hello.
Wow!
Cave.
They all went to the mountain.
They went to the mountain.
What could be there?
like a pilgrimage like a journey when I think when I'm back either when I'm back from Japan or in Japan I think I'm gonna play mist I wanted to honestly play it this week but I only picked games that I could like beat in one sitting so that I wasn't having anything oops having anything that I didn't already have finished.
Before I left, you know.
Where is that guy?
Oh, there he is.
Oh, I don't think he's...
Oh, I was going to say I don't think he's actively searching.
But he might be now.
Oh!
Maybe we're okay.
Hello, we're okay.
I'm scared.
Don't know anything about Mist myself.
I only remember attempting to play it as a wee...
We ghost.
um failing
we are going the right way still though right
the music is so intense
there's a I don't think he's searching actively right now oh yeah let's go to this one over here oh god uh oh uh oh uh oh I Eyeball!
Eyeball!
Eyeball?
How did he see you?
I guess he is active.
How did he...
How did that...
Ah!
Holy...
Cow!
What the heck just happened?
Eyeball!
Eyeball, don't die on me!
Where are you?
Oh, you're right next to me.
Okay.
Oh my god, oh my god, oh my god, oh my god, oh my god, oh my god, oh my god, oh my god, oh my god, oh my god, oh my god, oh my god, oh no, oh no, oh no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, Running, running.
Inside, inside, inside.
Hi-bo!
Hi-bo, hi-bo!
Okay.
Alright.
Jurassic Park theme would also fit this moment.
Go!
Hi-bo, go!
I watched the new Jurassic world.
Ketil-Kolatus is in it.
I was very happy about that.
But, well, I didn't dislike it.
I thought it was fine still.
What is it?
Rebirth, or?
I thought it was fine.
The Gravestones.
Surprise, I made another one.
I only watched it because Chris Pratt was not in it.
So, I watched it because he wasn't in it.
It's now like...
They're like mutant...
Mutant, uh...
Dinosaur or something?
Whoa.
As soon as we defrost them, they freeze back up.
No, defrost!
Defrost!
The music!
It's so beautiful.
I'm assuming is there stuff down here?
Is there secret stuff?
Hold on, let me check, let me look around.
I feel like there's probably something in there.
No?
Nothing?
Okay.
Thank you, guys.
Nothing important at this point.
Come on, Aibo!
Why do you hate the guy who's gonna play you in the Phantom Movie?
Don't say it!
Everybody knows Jack Black will play me.
Ooh, breezy!
Watch out!
Don't get swept away now.
Anything over here?
No.
You don't have to follow me, Aibo.
I'm just looking.
Wee!
Hold your ground!
Stay strong!
Hold your ground, hold your ground.
Oh my gosh.
Oh my gosh!
Hold your ground.
Run, run, run.
Run, run, run, run, run.
Ow, I fall!
Hold!
Hold on!
Maybe we can make it to the next ledge.
Over here!
Oh, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, nice, nice, nice, nice.
Uh-oh.
Yeah, we're fine, we're fine, we're fine.
We're not fine.
Everything's bad.
Hang right!
Okay, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go.
Go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go.
Okay, maybe.
Oh my gosh, there's like, oh my gosh, wait, this is evil.
Oh!
Ah!
Hi, Bo.
I feel like that has to happen.
Maybe?
Okay.
Oh, oh, I went into the snow.
Oh.
Whoa.
Wait, where are we?
Okay.
Yeah, our scarf is so small now.
What happened to it?
Does it keep getting blown away?
Whoa!
Oh my gosh, just go, I will go, go!
It's cold.
Is it?
It keeps breaking off?
Is that why?
Oh my gosh, our scarves are so small now!
Oh no, no, we have to make it!
And there's a bad guy.
Oh my gosh, big baddie.
Oh, I can
do is sing.
Push, push, push!
The mountain looks so far away, though.
The peak looks so far away.
Oh, my gosh.
Huddle close.
There's so many...
How did they put the gravestones up here?
We've come so far.
We can't freeze over now.
We can't.
We're slower.
We're getting slower, I think.
No, no, no.
No, we're getting slower.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
No, no, no.
Just keep... I'm pushing as hard as I can.
You can't even hear my voice anymore!
Oh my gosh, we're almost there.
Wait, the top of the mountain is gone.
Are we here?
Wait, where are we?
Oh my god, no!
This is like actually going up to Everest!
We gotta start taking our clothes off!
No!
No, don't stop.
Don't stop moving, eyeball.
I'm sorry, my head is blocking eyeball.
Boom boom boom boom boom boom boom boom boom boom boom boom boom boom boom boom
boom boom Is that my ancestors, question mark?
They're judging me.
They say even you failed.
You were supposed to be the prophesized one.
Save me, bird woman.
Yes!
Wow!
saying oh my god okay avoid those guys
and even further beyond
eyeball is that you eyeball Eyeball, look.
Eyeball, it's so beautiful.
Well, now here.
Inside?
Okay.
Wee!
Are you
behind me?
Whoa!
Mito just too fast.
My bad.
Hi Boa, we're here together.
We're here together.
I'm zooming.
If I'm missing stuff, sorry.
I'm just having too much fun.
No secrets here?
Okay!
Thank you!
I should go further up but I don't know how to move.
Wait, I'm stuck.
Wait.
I messed up.
There we go.
There we go, there we go.
Where'd my eyeball go?
Oh, there you are.
Aw, did you wait for me?
Much better eyeball than me.
I'm gonna kiss them!
Those sweet, sweet thighs!
Wow, it's so beautiful.
It's so beautiful.
Oh, you can't hear my voice in here.
I'm trying to talk to you, Eibu.
Can you hear me?
Wait, our scarf is once again gone.
Don't get so close to me.
Eibu.
Keep your distance.
Oh, don't get caught on the rocks, seriously.
You can still see me trying to talk to him.
No eye in this eyeball.
We're going into the lie.
There they go.
There we go.
Look at us with just two little triangles.
I can't tell if I still see us or if that's a speck on my monitor.
It's a speck on my monitor.
Oh my god, it's happening.
Thank you for playing Journey.
Wow.
Who's that?
It's going inside.
Well,
all the places we passed.
Our journey, our journey.
Our journey.
We didn't really travel so far, huh?
Sometimes the journey is harsh and bleak, but all you can do is keep going.
And the whole thing that... and it's the whole thing that makes you you yeah Thank you Murphy
As someone that like really enjoys the travel part of Of like traveling You know, not always just the destination part.
You know, I appreciate all sorts of journeys.
All throughout life and afterlife.
I don't think they warned people there'd be co-op.
Oh, really?
Yeah, the gameplay and aesthetics are very satisfying.
That's very true.
Oh.
so pretty oh my gosh oh my gosh so pretty life before death journey before destination
now we have to see Ibo's name when will it show wait hold on I have to grab my phone I have to make sure that I'm not missing anything real quick.
Sorry, hold on.
Okay.
It got even more beautiful.
Now I'm super mad.
Ibo, don't go, aren't we the star together?
Oh, there it is.
Companions met along the way.
What a reveal!
Thank you, Cash Money Robot!
I've never only seen one companion before.
What do you mean?
Is that about how many times you've played?
Because this is my first time playing.
Legendary way to end.
My starting one left.
Oh!
Oh, wait, I did get some achievements.
Let me see what they were.
Library.
Journey.
I unlocked.
Reaching the summit with a companion and return to the beginning.
Finish the game and return to the beginning.
Oh wait, so if you don't even have your companion, I guess if they die, right?
It was Cash Money Robot, they said so earlier.
Truly the deep emotional-spiritual connection we formed on this journey with Cash Money Robot.
That was the best reveal.
Ah!
Thank you for being my eyeball!
That was such a good reveal.
faded in.
Let's see.
Finish the game with the same partner for the majority of the journey and return to the beginning.
Only 14% of players have that achievement.
Wow.
Well, thank you, Cashman, you robot, for for what's the word?
For being my companion and finishing the game with me.
I really appreciate it.
Let's see.
I'm looking at some of the locked achievements.
Start the journey again after a week-long break, okay?
It's like cookie clicker.
Find the hidden desert flower.
Oh, interesting.
Discover all cloth creatures in the desert.
Oh, we didn't find all of them?
Meet 10 or more unique travelers.
Sit and meditate with another player for more than 20 seconds.
How do you sit?
Maybe if I stop moving, it's an idle animation.
Find a mysterious creature hidden in the temple.
Collect all unique glowing symbols across one or more journeys.
Cross the broken bridge without completely rebuilding it.
Ooh, cool.
Uncover all 10 ancient glyphs.
Dang it.
Pass through 15 gates while surfing through the sunken city.
You just go AFK.
Ah, okay, okay.
You did a lot of stuff for me.
No, these are not the things that I did.
These are the locked ones.
These are the ones that you can still get.
I only got four achievements.
Which was...
Sneak through the underground passage without tearing your scarf.
Finish the game and return to the beginning.
Reach the summit with a companion and return to the beginning.
And finish the game with the same partner for the majority of the journey.
And return to the beginning.
Yeah.
You can get those outside the map in the sun.
city.
Wait, get what?
Pretty nice game to replay, too.
Seems like it, right?
If you get all scarf upgrades, you unlock white robes.
Really?
Oh, cool.
I do want to maybe play again.
Maybe one day, like, a member stream or something, and somebody can help me get through.
We can play more together, like, more games together.
And maybe, like, different people can help me get different things or something like that.
Mm-hmm.
So pretty.
Wee!
So pretty!
Oh my gosh.
Wee!
Hmm.
Still need to get an Ocelot skin from Foxhunt.
I know.
The game matches you with a different companion whenever you change map.
The magic is that you don't know it.
It's rare to make a journey with only one partner, but with less online players.
Oh!
I see!
So first playthrough, you only match with first players, which makes the population the match smaller.
Wow!
Oh my gosh!
Also, thank you so much for the Aka doing a...
Aka super, thank you!
Oh, wow!
Wait, so like, if someone else were trying to play...
And...
Like...
Wow, so the fact that we...
That it was me and Cash Money Robot the whole time is, like, super...
rare?
That's crazy!
Wait, that's so cool though at the same time.
Wowee!
It will only swap if you get too far away from each other.
Because online is low probably.
Yeah, probably nowadays it's pretty easy to get that achievement I'd say.
If, well, Hmm?
Maybe.
Oh, I'm looking at like some of the other achievements.
The Ancestors One.
Find a mysterious creature hidden in the temple.
Only 8% of players.
Collect all unique glowing symbols across one or more journeys.
8%!
Back in the day, there was a dedicated community of white cloak players that would guide people through the game and help them find all the secrets.
That's so sweet!
That's so cute.
Well guys, thank you.
Well, that's another game off the list, I suppose.
Another completion.
Let me add it to my...
To my...
Try Princess!
Thank you!
Also Daily Dio, I'm so sorry I think I missed your don't know earlier.
It's one of my favorite games of all time, short and sweet.
Just like me too.
Alright.
Let's see.
18.
How many do we have left then?
Uh...
11!
11 games left and I'll have completed...
50.
Whoa!
Come back to pink.
Thank you!
Pink for the sunset tan!
It was scary to lose the scarf in the snow, though not sure taking clothes off would have held.
Thankfully the real scarf was you all on!
Thank you, Darko!
Thank you so much for the peek.
And yu yu yu yu yu yu yu yu yu yu yu yu yuni!
Thanks for this astonishing and beautiful experience, Minky and Cash Buddy Robot!
I've never played this game, but it did bring me beautiful memories of Sky Children, and of the Light and Abzu.
Oh yeah, I might!
I might check out the other games by...
by this team, so...
I stretch.
Oh, I've been...
It's been a very busy day for me.
I woke up and immediately started getting to work.
Not only on catch-up from stuff that I...
That I missed, but like...
Lots of stuff...
Lots and lots of planning still happenings for this week.
Thanks for the stream.
It was a good distraction.
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you.
ketchup ketchup
but thank you guys so much for hanging out with me for this short and sweet journey I had so much fun and it was very satisfying and beautiful such a beautiful game oh that was my controller disconnecting thanks for taking us on this journey thank you thank you thank you yeah hmm So,
um, I'll head out now since I have a meeting, or no, I'm meeting with Vicky and Phoebe in 30 minutes, so I will go, I will go get ready for that, and thank you all for hanging out with me.
I had a lot of fun.
Um, uh, uh, did I post the schedule on YouTube?
Well, regardless, I'll check, but, um, But, uh, uh, lots of streams this week.
I tried to, since I was gone last week, most of it.
And then also, I'll be gone for the next two weeks, most of it.
Um, and I have some collabs this week.
I tried to, like, double up a little bit extra to, as much as I could.
So, it's a pretty packed week.
So, lots and lots of streams.
Thanks for the streaming,!
I'm watching you play this beautiful game.
I'm Dragos, thank you!
Thank you, thank you.
Anyway, I'm going to head out now, so...
Take care!
I will see you when I see you next!
Bye-bye!
Bye-bye-bye-bye-bye-bye-bye-bye!
Bye-bye-bye-bye-bye-bye-bye!
how I was like my screen protector is all full of scuffs now that drop really did a big scuff on my screen protector I think I'll have to replace it when I dropped my phone earlier I guess
better the screen protector than my own phone though right